yeah I know a lot of people want me to
review Fifty Shades of Shi porn but
we're reviewing the Kingsmen because all
those two movies only one movie has an
action sequence that goes down to the
song Freebird Fifty Shades has all the
anal fisting going onto the song
Freebird we'd be doing that right now
but it doesn't so we're here
Kingsman the Secret Service girl I that
movie makes you want to dress up so here
we are so Kingsman the Secret Service is
directed by Matthew Vaughn is ultimately
imagined men in black meets James Bond
with no alien if James Bond was rebuilt
from the ground up for this current
generation that's the Kingsmen it's a
pretty kick-ass time - I mean Matthew
Vaughn's given us x-men first class
ironically enough cuz I just said it's
the kick-ass time kick-ass dude has some
credentials and now he's bringing us
this British spy movie about
international secret agents all
gentlemen who dress really sure in
Kingsman Colin Firth he's one of the
Kingsmen he finds his young kid he's got
all the potential in the world and he's
a son of a former king's man he's like
alright we'll come and be a Kingsman
just like Tommy Lee Jones did with Will
Smith and men in black Sammy well
Jackson was the bad guy and you know
he's up to no good and they give him
this weird Lisp you know and he talks
like this you know it's a she is just
going down kissed in this I
sounded like Mike Tyson so it's funny
when they give villains weird voices for
the sake of giving them weird voices I
always find that strange but in it kind
of being a James Bond omage the girl
who's working for samuel l.jackson her
legs are like amputated and they turn
into blades i was like that is
old-school James Bond I mean the
characters are great I love Colin Firth
in this movie I love Colin Firth kind of
kicking his feet up and he's like hey I
can be awesome I could be a badass I can
be relatable I feel like if kids watch
this movie and they're playing on the
playground in school or in the
neighborhood but that is to say if they
have bad parents that let them watch
Kingsman this rated our movie they'd
want to be Colin Firth you know taking
the umbrella hook in the glass flicking
the glass shattering out on someone's
head you know this whole action sequence
goes down some of it's very shaky
cameras but I feel like Matthew Vaughn's
the guy who can use shakey cam and use
it well enough the camera kept following
all the action well enough to go all
right it's a shakey cam that's okay and
this movie doesn't hold back I mean
there are scenes where all my old Colin
Firth is stabbing that guy in the eye
folks are dying folks folks are
dying I've always liked Matthew Vaughn
in that sense it's always like he just
takes his characters directions where
some other people be like I don't know
if we can have mr. Colin Firth do that
so we're not gonna have him do that
Matthew Vaughn's like no make it work
make it happen because that's what would
happen there were a couple of moments of
wasted potential like the Nemesis
character to our main star in the movie
who died this kid I have seen him in
nothing I cannot think of anything he's
been in but something tells me I'm gonna
see a lot more of him he was great in
this movie and there's just like you
know this nemesis character when he's
training and trying to become a Kingsman
and later on you're like oh
a wild card it looks like they
might go somewhere with that nope it's
just it doesn't go anywhere it's nothing
that kind of bummed me out I was like I
would've been cool but okay we go on
with Kingsman Kingsman is very
self-aware too it makes movie references
and it jabs at the fact that if this was
a movie this is what would happen I love
it when movies are self-aware of the
fact that they too might be moving
Indian Kingsman had great characters
great action I love it when all these
people are gentlemen they're so just
proper they will hold the door open for
a lady and kick the out of her
scumbag boyfriend I love characters like
that I love people like that I love
movies like this I can see Kingsman
being this new franchise in the vein of
James Bond and born in the fact that
Matthew Vaughn did this movie means he
will be attached to no sequels
whatsoever I will slay Kingsman the
Secret Service is awesome tacular I
really want to see Matthew Vaughn and
stick around for the sequels just for
once special Kingsman the Secret Service
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more